when you're growing up you come here
what's your mentality about how you're
going to take advantage of being in
America are you looking at it like I'm
going to start my own business I have
capitalism at my fingertips no I came
here not trusting America I came here
like looking at the white man like I've
learned a lot about you Mr white man I
see you coming to school in the BMW and
we're coming in and they used 79 Honda
Accord hatchback you know that only goes
Drive doesn't go reverse okay you're
special you think you're better than me
right so that that bit of animosity or
kind of looking at them uh funny that
was there there was nothing about I'm
gonna come here to become rich and do
this no of course don't get me wrong I
was the dreamer since I was a kid